nothing Cuts away at the conviction of
the left on this issue more than the
grooming gang Scandal they will deploy
any method whatsoever to discredit the
people who raise it
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator over the last 40 to 50 years
thousands if not tens of thousands of
young girls and young women across
Britain
have been abused raped and some of them
brutally murdered in what we know as the
great grooming gangs Scandal last week
prime minister Rishi sunak and his Home
Secretary swella bravaman announced
policies to deal with the grooming gang
this new policy has kicked up a lot of
the issues that have plagued the story
for the last 20 years and I'm here to
try and get into the story in the
history is documentary filmmaker and
journalist Charlie Peters Charlie thank
you so much for coming to speak with me
today thank you very much for having me
so uh Charlie was the director of the
film grooming gangs Britain's shame
which was released earlier this year and
it's actually pretty harrowing
unpleasant watching but a significant
significant and important film
nonetheless
um
and also Charlie has just come back from
interviewing the Home Secretary swella
Braven so I thought perhaps we should
start before going into the history of
it all in the complex industry that will
start with the prime minister's announce
policy Charlie perhaps perhaps you can
you can let me know what you think about
the announcement well the headline
policy is the NCAA supported task force
it's the National Crime agency so a new
task force has been set up for across
the country in in England that is
specifically for a task force to go into
and support police forces dealing with
child sexual exploitation and
specifically Under The Grooming model of
exploitation now
um this is a very exciting policy
because the National Crime agency have
enjoyed significant success when they've
investigated Rotherham kind of the
the headline of this National scandal in
terms of the towns affected by it there
are also a couple of other smaller
policies announced with this raft of new
packages
um possibly this most significant after
the task force is this new focus on the
collection of ethnicity data significant
struggle for governments in the last
decades since this story really erupted
and that there's not been a clear
picture of the ethnicity data there's
been lack of understanding there they've
also introduced a new mandatory
reporting Bill to uh report so that
child safeguarding professionals now
must report when they suspect an
incident of child sexual abuse now
mandatory reporting has been campaigned
for in many forms for various different
groups for a long time and it was a
recommendation of the independent
inquiry into child's sexual abuse
published last year so that's also a
significant announcement also among the
announcements are
um I think also very importantly
a new minimum punishment for grooming
gang offenders in terms of imprisonment
we'll go into this later I'm sure but
very new serious aggravating offense
that's right so a new minimum kind of
judicial sentence because it's all too
often uh offenders have been released
from prison after a few years and
they've not managed to secure the the
sentence that was appropriate and also
there's more money for a whistleblowing
helpline that the nspcc runs 600 000
pounds for them so it's a significant
raft of measures and the reason why I'm
well acquainted with them is that the
NCAA supported task force the new
um the new minimum sentencing
regulations and indeed the focus on
holding the police to account on
ethnicity data are three policies that
are explicitly called for in my film
grooming gang Britain shame for GB news
so the policies have when it's the
highlight of my career probably will be
forever they've been they've been lifted
directly from the film into law within
two months so how do you think uh we can
see their effectiveness like what seeing
as you have come up with these policies
why do you think that they're going to
work and and how do we know whether
they're they're affected sure ask the
same question to the homosexual Monday
how are you judge in particular the the
new task force how will its success be
given she gave me a pretty wuffly answer
um so there's still you have to be
holding this government to account oh no
I will hold this can't buy checking
whether or not new perpetrators are
found and whether or not the parachuted
in specialist CSA experts within the
police do indeed put the money where
their mouth is and with these new
resources actually secure the
prosecutions that so many are asking for
because when the NCA was brought into
Rotherham they did make dozens of more
prosecutions and they did find over a
hundred more survivors During the period
they're investigating so I think it's
highly likely that the NCAA supported
task force when it is called in to the
various towns that um discourages has
hit and we found up to 50 different
towns and cities in the 18 months long
investigation for the film where
grooming gangs have been credible
reports of grooming gangs have been
found I will hold them to account by
checking whether or not they are finding
these perpetrators and whether the
pathetic approach to dealing with these
gangs is finally reverted on the minimum
sentencing that's pretty easy to check
our grooming gang abusers being released
from prison after two or three years how
are many cases are they going to open
prison after serving a quarter of their
sentence as some of them have
and that's actually uh I think what was
the case with the recent and it's been I
think you might even described it as the
Icebreaker case
um that the high court awarded Survivor
uh 425 000 pounds this is a only a few
weeks ago right
um where rapist and groomer asgar Boston
not only he only served
half of his sentence but that was served
in an open
prison yeah and that's Survivor
Elizabeth I mean I've worked with her
for 18 months in the course of my
investigation one of the several
survivors she's the victim she's the
Survivor of this this particular abuser
um she launched that Icebreaker legal
case because she thought the state was
not supporting her she was not receiving
the justice that she needed from The
Authority sworn to protect her and you
know appallingly had to take justice
into her own hands not a sort of
vigilante way although I think some of
that might have been legitimate but more
having to in her own civil case
pursue a prosecution and a civil Victory
against terribusa which he's achieved
and I think this will open up
hundreds possibly thousands of more
cases for survivors to think hang on I
can actually finally achieve something
that the state has failed me for but now
with this announcement last week there
is the hope that
two things can happen at once yeah
survivors can achieve their own justice
but the state can also step in at the
same time and ensure that there aren't
more survivors like that and many
thousands waiting for the Justice they
deserve I think with the case of
Elizabeth it's worth noting that for
anyone who didn't have any doubt and an
open prison means that they are actually
free to roam and have to go check in at
the end of the day to prison so not that
much from being different from being
free yeah
um uh so do you think with both that
case and this case are you optimistic
then is this is this a turning point in
The Grooming gang Scandal that's my hope
I mean I feel cautiously optimistic and
indeed that's the language that I heard
from Maggie Oliver a significant
campaigner in this story and three
survivors I I spoke to in person on
Monday in Rochdale who they had just met
the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary moments before to discuss the
policy and to share their experiences
they'll all be the same thing that they
were first year late is just to have
someone at the top of government
actually take them seriously for once
because well we've had so many prime
ministers and last five minutes but in
the decades since this Scandal erupted
they haven't none of them have taken
this problem seriously I don't think
even slightly and I think there is you
know like I said a cautious optimism
that with these policies if they are
followed through properly change will
happen with that plus Elizabeth having
her extraordinary win not about the
money about Justice
I mean it's yeah it's like the first
time this story has been able to
generate Smiles so with this in both
cases and particularly last week
with the announcement from the
government uh whole the the same old
sort of Kickback has has erupted with uh
amongst other politicians
um uh labor pushing back against it but
also the media and this is this has
really been what has clouded the whole
story and what makes it such a complex
story to really understand so
um and that I don't know if it's an
appropriate starting point but the
what's the the the the root of the
contention whether it's the media or
politicians
is the ethnic
makeup and and representation among
amongst abusers and
um uh victims and survivors now actually
and and perhaps this is contentious
swella Braven in Her speech said
local reviews in in Rochdale rotherman
Telford exposed the systemic rape abuse
and exploitation of vulnerable young
women and girls by organized gangs
almost all of them British Pakistani men
yeah now
there have been various
um reports uh over over the last 10 15
years 20 years
suggesting a mix here so on the one hand
there's some extremes would suggest I
think the quillium report in 2017
suggested that 86 something like 84 87
percent were British Pakistani men but
then and this is what you got at in your
film
that actually there was uh it was 30
white men of the abusers and 28 percent
that's from the 2020 home office report
but do you accept those numbers only a
small portion of oh the home of support
found that data collection on ethnicity
had been extremely poor across the
country so deep was the sense of concern
about the racialized background of this
crime and so strong was the shrouding
sense of political correctness that
police forces and local councils and
researchers and government data had
simply failed to collect the data they
just hadn't done it so many police
forces had none at all and indeed since
the homeost report was published in 2020
some police forces have been found to
still be failing to collect the data so
there has been a reticence to establish
the truth about this which is why you're
so happy about the new policy too yes
because I think they'll not be held to
account they have to do it now I mean
and they will be punished if they don't
but this problem has been going on for
so long and people always refer back to
this 2020 home office reports when they
say oh look majority of abusers are
white that's obviously the case this is
a majority white country 85 percent of
the country is white and so you'd expect
with that proportion of the population
most abuses to be white but when you
actually you know consider things per
capita and by proportionality even with
the home offices very weak data and
underreported collection of data from
police forces
British pakistanis in particular are
vastly overrepresented up to over 10
times more likely to be a grooming gang
abuser according to their own weak
statistics now
um in a study that literally no one has
responded to me on in terms of the
people who are very happy to run this
line that the grooming gangs are not a
kind of Asian or Pakistani problem
by comparing the number of prosecutions
with the overall population you actually
do find that British pakistanis in
particular and British Muslims in
general
dominates grooming gang statistics I
that it's the statistics are extremely
troubling
um I think it found by looking at kind
of names and comparing them in court
records They found that one in every 2
200 Muslim men over 16 in England and
Wales between 97 to 2017 had been
prosecuted for this crime and when you
drive it down into the specific towns
where this abuse has happened but we
know they've been massive massive
scandals that figure tightens enormously
it tightens so much in Rotherham that
it's one in every 72 British Pakistani
has been prosecuted for these crimes and
that matches with what we know happened
on the ground I mean the J reports
published in 2014 found that despite
being two to three percent of the
population
um the British Pakistani population of
Northern about eight thousand
they were vastly over represented in
grooming gang abuse of 1400 Girls It's a
Small Town a sense of percentage of when
you say vastly of represented like what
what sort of
and what sort of what would that number
look like like literally every girl
reported their abuser as being Asian and
they didn't so there are no examples of
like non-asians I between 97 and 2013
there are other examples of other users
of course but
um the vast vast majority well of that
of that Heritage and when the home
office conducted studies in the town in
the early naughties they also found that
abuse Rings were centered around small
Pakistani families in Rotherham as well
so the representation was clear the same
Trend was found in Rochdale and more
recently it was found also in Telford
and
and every time where this
over-representation has been found and
it is vast
at the same time an equally troubling
trend is found insofar as those sworn to
protect women and girls in those towns
choose to remove statistics on ethnicity
from their reports or they do not pursue
abusers because they fear doing so would
look racist they do not start
investigations into areas of the
population such as taxi drivers because
that's an area of particular Pakistani
Heritage in many of these towns because
they think it's going to be racist that
fundamentally they did not protect girls
because they thought it would be racist
this was the consistent theme in those
three major towns and I think that's
replicated elsewhere as well I I do want
to get into the the political
correctness aspect because that seems to
be a phenomenon that's driven a lot of
the confusion around around this topic
not only in how we understand it but in
the mechanisms of play in dealing with
it but but with I guess what I'm trying
to get at is there's a lot of talk about
these being Pakistani men what is it
about why why is there that hammering
that it's Pakistan what is it about the
culture of Pakistani men that is
different from let's say the white
people who are who are in grooming gangs
I would say that the overall cause of
these crimes across the board regardless
of ethnicity is
um a misogynistic violent hate of girls
in exchange for sex people who want to
abuse
the defenseless and the innocent for
their own pleasure that is the most
consistent theme across them now
where you find particular over
representation among the Pakistani
Community there are more factors at play
so
um there is a racialized elements
insofar as white girls are considered
fair game by many of the abusers how
have you come to that conclusion the
testimony of the survivors and the
victims in court the statements of the
abusers themselves in court in their
police questioning
um survivors telling me and indeed many
other journalists that they were
referred to as white slags white [__]
as worthless meat essentially and and
that's that the polite end of the
spectrum of some of the horrifying
language that they were used in
um white girls being passed Round in
Circles by men in a ball while they were
subjected to racial abuse
um this element of the crisis is never
really referred to by the rest of the
media and that it was a racialized crime
and there are reasons why people often
don't discuss that we have a very
um broken understanding of racism in
Britain where we think of it like they
do in the US in terms of systemic and it
can only go in One Direction or the
other there is this feeling of its
privilege and power and therefore you
can't be racist to white people Etc well
clearly these men
or extremely racist as they chose to
attack white girls and describe him in
that term many survivors also heard the
term gory gory girls which is a kind of
um
a term to describe them as kind of
worthless as well only nine defendants
who actually appeared in court during
the prosecutions into Rochdale the lead
defendant um sabir Ahmed the objected to
being tried by an all-white's jury I
mean they understood their own defense
in racialized terms there was a real
clear sense of one Community versus
another this is a crisis of
multiculturalism in general and British
immigration policies of the last 50
years we very quickly create separate
societies but when that blurred into
abuse that creates an extremely
dangerous situation
there are also
um
additional
cultural measures that made it difficult
to prosecute these gangs and made it
more difficult to infiltrate understand
and investigate what they were doing and
that it was in the case of British
Pakistan is the the prevalence of a kind
of clanish attitudes
this is born out of I believe kind of
sociobiological kinship cousin marriage
is very common among the British
Pakistani population in Bradford for
example a town which is very heavily
Asian and Pakistani in particular
um birth defects are well above the
average rate across the country because
first cutter marriage is so common now
when so many of your local community and
it's a very tight-knit community on
geographical lines but also on ethnic
lines there's so many people who live
around you are your blood brother your
blood cousin you are less likely to dump
them in and you're also more likely to
associate them associate with them
and be aligned with them in your life
um this makes it harder for
investigators if they even do want to
tackle them to break into that Ned to
find someone who would give them support
someone to whistleblow
there also is also another Factor at
play here I mean we could I could talk
about that for hours but we probably
shouldn't another Factor at play would
be also
the extremely misogynistic
values and attitudes that are prevalent
among some immigrant groups more than
the kind of indigenous English or
British population so
it is true value is imported from yeah
values imported from the mere pure
region of Pakistan are not the same as
they are in Progressive parts of
Richmond shall we say you know now
Richmond to North Yorkshire or Richmond
Southwest London
now
many many Pakistani girls were abused by
these gangs sometimes they're family
members what percentage of the girls we
just don't know we just don't know the
data isn't there but in terms don't know
what percentage of the girls were what
many of the survivors doesn't come
forward sure but what we know in terms
of what we know it's like almost all but
of but a lot of a lot of the data is
missing on the on the survivors as well
but almost all young girls are white and
Britain there we go yeah so
it wouldn't necessarily primarily be a
race hate crime it would be a sexual
abuse crime these men just are just
sexual perverts right and primarily and
and the race factor maybe is a secondary
thing I don't when the murderer when the
murder of Stephen Lawrence happened
and he was killed by a white gang nobody
turned around and said ah but the
majority of men in England are white so
what you know the abusers being white
doesn't mean that it was racist I think
it's clear in the language they used and
the way they targeted them and knowing
that their immediate availability of the
girls around them were their own
Heritage that they chose to Target white
girls instead now there are so many
other reasons why but I think it's
really important to nail this point
about misogyny as well because they had
a hateful understanding of what women
were worth and in many cases that's
still true so
women in South Asian and Pakistani
backgrounds in particular in Britain
don't have a lot of cultural or economic
power they're often allowed to work
they're not allowed to leave their home
they don't have a say in what happens
and so
when
young Asian girls were abused by these
gangs as they often were indeed Often by
their own family members in the case of
the lead defendant in Rochdale that was
true while also running a gang of white
girls he abused he also sexually
assaulted and raped for many years a
family member
when that happens
there is an additional layer preventing
those girls from coming forward and
telling their story because it might
destroy their marriage prospects because
if you come from
an extremely poor town and live in an
extremely poor family in
a very backwards looking cultural setup
and family
often marriage is your only way to get
by your family might not allow you to
work they might not allow you to have a
lot of Education they might say you
reach a certain point now you're backing
and you're looking after the men that
that's also caused a significant problem
it also meant that when men were abusing
white girls
their families would not dub them in
because the women had no power to object
to what their husbands were doing that
also means that when they leave prison
after serving short sentences the ones
that we know have been prosecuted and
imprisoned in all the cases I've tracked
I can't find a single example of a
grooming gang rapist leaving prison and
being banished by his community they go
home
they go home they might move their home
they might move with their family to
another part of the country
in the case of a notorious abuser in
hell but he just moved 50 miles down the
road but he moved with his wife
and that's true a lot of these places
now
when a white man goes to prison for
child abuse
he's often killed more often than he is
allowed to return to his family okay is
that what statistically no I mean just
that happens a lot pedophiles are often
demolished in prison a lot of them end
up with that the most the most appalling
abusers
often
meet a violent Justice they wouldn't
otherwise receive at the hands of the
state while in prison and
if they do get out
I certainly on Welcome Back With Open
Arms by the places they used to live in
or at least if they are as I'm sure they
do in some cases
the rate of that is significantly than
it is among Asian communities so I think
that's a really important way of
understanding why one of the reasons why
this Scourge has continued for so long
and this is an area of investigation
that many people have just completely
ignored one of the I think successes of
of your film is is humanizing and
turning the statistics into
into real life stories uh
particularly given that so many of the
victims and survivors
are not in a position where they can
come come out and and talk about it it's
notable
that we don't have there isn't a
household name for a Survivor despite
and and this is pretty striking but
there's the case of Laura Wilson
age 17 stabbed 14 times to death for
revealing to the family of her abuser
that uh that they were they had some
sort of relationship and then Lucy Lowe
aged 15 burnt to death with her mother
sister and unborn child
these aren't household names and and
this is such an extensive horrific
Scandal
um and I I wondered if if you what
Insight you gleaned into the the the
type of girls that are falling prey to
these abusers
this is difficult this is a really
difficult area of discussion
um where again with much of this Scandal
there is a an incomplete picture of
understanding based on the statistical
analysis there is not enough data or
investigation from Social Services who
often actively ignored
discussing this problem
a big problem within this Scandal is
that the girls have often been derided
as being
Reckless off the loose
uh
uh Wilds young things going crazy and
having Asian boyfriends
or at the same time they've been
described as kind of damaged girls in
care
who are you know
not bothered by the protection of the
states and nobody cares about them
um
neither do those things describe the
full extent of the story
um
a small portion of the girls who have
been abused by these gangs were in care
a lot of them had loving parents all of
them had stable families
um but because of the complete ignorance
of the local authorities and the police
they were caught up in this Whirlwind of
abuse child sexual exploitation doesn't
just happen to weak children who are
poor and ignored
it happens to people who are isolated by
meticulous and evil men and indeed often
captured by women in a trend that hasn't
really been discussed a lot of women
used by these gangs to lure in and gain
the trust of girls
who are naive and children and innocent
and and Trust adults
so
because of the very few number of
survivors who are public
and yeah that's a handful who are in the
media and if they are in the media
they're often
doing so anonymously that's all of the
survivors I work with are
when there are many reasons why they're
Anonymous I mean they're abusers often
just out and about still or if they've
been punished they've returned they see
them in the supermarket they see them in
the street they see them at work
sometimes
but also because I don't
I mean in the case of at least one
Survivor I know very well I mean they
just don't trust the public to
acknowledge and appreciate their story
they think that they will be sacrificed
on the altar of political correctness
and that their testimony will be heard
ignored and recycled in favor of
protecting the status quo the dominant
culture and the preference for
Community cohesion over the truth right
in that situation who can blame them for
staying hidden who can blame the number
of you know
the possible thousands of survivors who
have not come forward with their stories
that's one of the questions actually
asked for the Raven on Monday last week
was
you know
what would you say to
the women and girls who have been too
afraid to tell their story because they
never felt that the police or the
government were on their side which is
how they have felt and why and they
should feel that way I mean they should
feel because the police and the
government have not been on their side
I was happy to describe it as a turning
point because I think I hope actually
that lots of women and girls do see this
as a moment when they can
start to constantly trust the
authorities one of the Striking things
about your film and something we should
get into which is the failure of local
councils local social services and local
police I mean one example again from
your film is is a young girl a young
Survivor going into the police station
and deciding to turn around before make
filing the report because she gets
spooked out of it she gets somehow
approached I don't know she had a
message on her phone got a message on
her phone saying that her brother has
been captured if she says anything
they'll break his legs or something she
don't her brother's legs had already
been broken by the gang
um her abuser message her on her phone
to say that he had her 11 year old
sister now the torment that she was
enduring was going to be passed on to
her sister and
a very brave researcher from the home
office this was in the early Northeast
you know 20 years ago now
um was sent up there to kind of
investigate what was going on in the
town in terms of drug dealing and then
quickly found actually there was a the
drug dealing in Rotherham was revolved
around an abuse ring and a child abuse
ring and so that she found that they
were connected and
these girls were being ignored by the
social services but this researcher from
London was establishing a link with
several survivors and convinced one of
the victims to kind of come forward with
her claims and then that happened gets
to the police station
how that message reached her and how the
abuser knew that she was in the police
station has never ever been explained
the report that unveiled that crisis
found no
kind of No Smoking Gun
but it's almost certain that he was
informed by someone in the police
station she was there and indeed
later one of the police officers in
Rotherham PC Hassan Ali
was placed under investigation
for his corrupt role or his alleged
corruption
and he died the same day he was run over
by a family friend I mean I spoke too
early about Clash attitudes and clannish
links and how people don't dub in their
family members
police officer is put under
investigation for his links to grooming
gangs and he is killed the same day run
over on a snowy Drive near Sheffield
I mean it's it's just it isn't a
coincidence that that happened in my
opinion okay I just think it's highly
highly unlikely highly highly unlikely
that on the same day the investigation
started he was killed
and
there's no inquisitive National
investigation into why that happened
there's no kind of urgent plea to to dig
into that and I tried trust me but it
happened so long ago and I'm in many
ways I'm late to the story right
but I can't find a great amount of
national agitation to try and find out
that link and and a part of the failure
has been political correctness aspect
and and
um
there were turning points and and we
should talk about uh I think
specifically Andrew Norfolk and and how
things seem to turn around but but
there's a there's a the political
correctness thing and the the the people
being too scared to address the cultural
differences yeah and those cultural
um crossfires that
um this seems to lie on what what do you
put that down to is that is that I mean
1999 was the McPherson report so
there's a sort of fear of being called
racist is it is it as is it as simple as
that is this is part of it but it's also
just there's a general shift in our
political culture towards
um like an Uber tolerance where reality
is sidelined in favor of prioritizing
the kind of the Zeal of diversity
whereby
um
different crimes committed by different
groups according to different failures
and different perspectives are sidelined
and are treated as kind of fake or or
not worthy of being prioritized because
that might
kind of cut away at the the number one
priority which is the defense of
multiculturalism multi-racialism and
kind of liberalism in our culture so
that is I think that is the overall
Scandal and the efforts of government
bodies Charities the Civil Service the
media all these groups to reinforce that
through things like MacPherson report
and other kind of discussions and
investigations only solidifies that kind
of political failure so that's part of
it that's a well the the the what
happened to Sarah champion at the labor
party issues and the shadow cabinet for
Jeremy corbyn wrote an article for the
Sun
at specifically saying this is a
cultural ethnic issue issue specifically
it's majority Pakistani men and she was
yeah there's things you can't say I mean
she was kicked out she kicked out of the
Shadow cabinet because so there were
there were repercussions which surely
just in just enforced the truth is not
acceptable in favor when it when it when
it beats down that kind of like the
religiously held perspectives of the
left in these in these cases and that's
true not just the politicians but also
of cultural people saying of the left
it's not been so clear
um that it that the left have even
though they're now pushing back but they
are in in opposition but labor MP and
crier yeah but she said he's one of the
first to report it and also Sarah
Champion there's some amount of Courage
for her in the first place to speak out
on this to write for the song on this so
actually it's not surely it's not that
simple as to say oh it's all the left
who have failed on this topic Ankara was
ignored and Sarah Champion was expelled
so that's how the left dealt with the
two brave people they've had who stood
forward
um if you're a conservative or if you're
on the right or whatever if you speak up
against this issue it doesn't harm your
life it doesn't ruin your political
career that's how I would describe the
split now I'm enormously grateful to
anyone who is you know politically read
or left-leaning or communitarian or
whatever who speaks up on this issue
especially if they have power because
they are doing something enormously
Brave which is telling the truth because
that's a scandalous thing to do if you
belong to the red team while also caring
about this issue
um but it's clear I think that
punishment for holding the wrong opinion
on this space has been predominantly
applied to those on the left because
like I said the the kind of the
deference towards diversity the
religiously held could like conviction
that diversity is a good thing cannot be
cut away by its critics and especially
not on something as damning as this
Scandal because this Scandal kind of
like
it it just it destroys that entire world
view it completely Cuts apart of the
idea that you can just transform a local
Society with completely alien culture
overnight or at least very very quickly
and expect everything to be fine it
completely destroys the Universalist
understanding of how these communities
should of how the world works the
understanding that like a global sense
of solidarity will mean that if you
bring you know thousands of people from
the mirpure region of Northern Pakistan
and then drop them into a depressed
Victorian mining town in South Yorkshire
that everything will be fine because
clearly it won't I mean in Oldham in
2001 this is in Lancashire there were
race riots I mean there have been
enormous periods of tension between the
local communities in these places
um
and nothing exposes it more nothing Cuts
away at at the conviction of the left on
this issue more than the grooming gang
Scandal it demolishes their worldview
they cannot allow it to be discussed
they cannot allow the data to be
collected they will refuse to bring this
up and every time the story comes in
they will deploy any method whatsoever
to discredit the people who raise it
they will describe you as racist they
will say that your data is false they'll
refer back to the dodgy 2020 home office
report they will do everything they can
to shut you down in Rotherham
where obviously so many counselors were
a disaster one man in particular was was
was singled out in in the Casey
reporting to Rotherham Council in 2015.
it's called mauru for saying he was the
community cohesion Minister just to
really ran this point home he accused
the fellow labor party member he made a
false accusation of racism against a
labor party member when they tried to
talk about the prominence of a Pakistani
taxi drivers in these gangs so it's just
it's a consistent thing that happens
across the board well
if it's a failure of the left I wouldn't
say the conservative party had been much
better and they've been in government
um and uh and this feels like the first
real movement after as we've said a
decades-long scandal so I'm not sure the
conservances No No are too much better
but it's certainly true that Lisa and
Andy said that um that the grooming
happens across all cultures and then
Yvette Cooper has come out
saying that these this new policy by the
Prime Minister isn't isn't going she
doesn't think it's going to be effective
yeah you've seen what she said I have
seen I've seen it all the questions well
West Yorkshire mayor Tracy Bradman said
on Sunday when swella Bravo made her
comments when she noted the prominence
of British pakistanis
Tracy rabbit I think perhaps
wasn't prepared for this wasn't prepared
for a politician to State the truth she
described it as dog whistle politics I
mean it's a prime example the story
comes up the issue is raised the
prominence of pakistanis in this story
is outlined the failure to deal with it
and the political correctness that
you know shrouded investigations and
blocked prosecutions and there we have
it on on the BBC Sunday morning a labor
politician saying oh this is a dog
whistle this is essentially saying
you're racist for doing this I mean it
could not be more clear that it's still
going on you know the reason why I made
the film
not only just obviously try and raise
attention to the policies I thought
would help but also to to restart the
national conversation on this issue and
one of the reasons why I've been
cautiously optimistic I'm elated that
these policies have been adopted and
that people are talking about it again
but I'm quite depressed because
everything I've seen in the last week
since the announcement was made
has been like the machine rising up to
destroy people who are making this point
Sue Ella braveman is racist Reggie sunak
is racist the people who may I mean I've
been called racist like over a thousand
times in the last week on Twitter just
for simply pointing out government data
local reports commissioned by social
workers for stating the truth I've been
you know Hillary statistics well how are
you supposed to solve a problem if
you're not able to diagnose the problem
very first place which again I don't see
anything you're saying is you're not
saying that Pakistani people or culture
is the problem is you're specifically
saying that these in these areas these
specific cultures have the have been a
problem we need to understand why that
is and that's that seems to me to be
what you're doing
um but nevertheless
one of the you know saying something
like dog whistles one of the the
parts of this complex story has been
that
the likes of Tommy Robinson have been
covering the story and it's sort of
become their preserve yeah and uh and
and it it just adds to that sort of
concept that it's it's it's it's a
far-right sort of fantasy
um um uh and and that's dominated even
after in Andrew norfolk's original
reporting in in 2003 for the times it
seems to have
well he didn't write anything in 2003.
and cry raised the problem in 2003 and
Andrew Norfolk dismissed he wrote one
story and he dismissed it as a far-right
fantasy now Andrew Norfolk is the times
journalist the investigator who kind of
blew the lid off this scandal in 2011
and 2012 when he wrote his reports from
Rotherham before eight or nine years
before he did that he was convinced he
had some sort of like liberal guilt he
had some he didn't really agree with
what Anne Cryer told him
um
but
you know a sense of
a journalistic sense that something
really was going on kicked in and he
started researching court records
met with Jane senior The Whistleblower
who was working in the social services
and Children's Services internal time
trying desperately to raise awareness
what was going on and his reporting in
the town
led to
an investigation by uh Alexis J the
social worker Professor Alexis J
so
up until that point the only people who
were talking about it were the far right
because there was a concerted effort on
the ground by the people who operated
politically in these areas predominantly
labor party trade unions and left-wing
organizations to shut it down but I've
um as part of my 18 months of obsessing
over this story I've looked through
leaflets from campaigns from like 2006
and in small towns like election like
Council election campaigns
not just from the labor party but also
like leafleting from groups like United
against fascism leafitting from Outreach
groups for like pro-migration bodies
I'm seeing
a uaf United States fascism leaflet that
said the BMP are spreading lies about
child Grooming by Pakistani men in this
town
there's a BNP would write about this
issue 20 years ago
you might think that their conclusions
were evil repatriation of pakistanis
um you know an all-white to England and
all the rest of it but in terms of
actually talking about this problem and
noting it was going on they were right
and everybody else ignored them right so
it's only been The Preserve of the far
right a term which is expanding of
course possibly to include me now
um because
others have ignored it right so if if
decent people and people from other
political Persuasions fail to recognize
and admit you know an epidemic of child
rape it is not the fault of the far
right for disgusting against the fault
of them for ignoring it and and the
consequence is that if it's only the far
right who are discussing it then it's
the only the far right who are coming up
with policy to try and deal with it
they're going to come up with extremist
abhorrent Solutions which we we cannot
have so the conversation needs to be had
so that we find serious solutions for
societal cohesion and for these young
girls who need Justice and and since the
policy announcements made last week I've
actually seen any criticism serious
criticism or uh an alternative proposal
by the people who are cutting away at
the ideas so
um
I just don't think people want to solve
the problem on on the other side as it
were or the people who don't want to
have this conversation about child
grooming gangs and sex gangs don't
really have alternative Provisions in
the same way or
um the labor party I mean when the
announcement mandatory reportering went
out he said I was calling for this 10
years ago and that's great I mean it's
fine to be cool yeah yeah sure I mean
people have been calling for mandated
reporting for decades and it's great
that it's finally being introduced but
in terms of specialist offices to deal
with gangs and a collection of ethnicity
data and a No Holds Barred investigation
and holding the police to account of
these areas nobody's been calling for
that until last week so no I just don't
I don't accept that they would come up
with Solutions without being prodded by
someone else one of the most
sad things about the film was that the
feeling that things weren't getting
better and even though these new
policies
seem to be a step in the right direction
is there anything that people let's say
watching can can do you know well the
reason why I know it's still going on is
just because I've been looking into it
for so long I work very closely with the
charity called The Magnolia Foundation
Mike Oliver is the greatest Manchester
police whistleblower who blew the lid on
the Rochdale Sex Gang Scandal
um she was part of a team that compiled
over 100 pedophiles onto a database in
Greater Manchester in Rochdale in
particular took some time off work
because her husband Norman died and when
she came back to work she found that the
database had been destroyed and none of
the prosecutions had been delivered
um
the last date for discussing
the database operation Orchestra was the
day before the 77 bombing and in the
film I questioned whether or not the uh
the sudden blast of an islamist attack
meant that police Chiefs in Greater
Manchester felt it was too difficult for
them to then start pursuing
predominantly Muslim men in in sex gangs
I think almost certainly that is the
case quotation Manchester police didn't
reach out to me when I asked them for
details
um so the magaloba foundation working
with them
I got to look at the work they were
doing got to look at their annual report
for this year before it was released
they've supported over a thousand
victims in the last two years who are
seeking support because they are being
[__] off by the police and Social
Services
currently working on over 60 live cases
of victims being abused by these gangs
across the country this is a small
charity so
we can take it as given that whatever
they capture is a small representation
of The Wider problem
um 100 seeking support for legal aid and
kind of emotional kind of therapy and
assistance in their lives because you
know obviously there's this can destroy
you
so yeah we do know it's still going on
and I've you know I've donated to the
magular foundation as I've worked along
and I would encourage others to do so
because I can't
find another group that's doing it as
good work as them while also being true
to the issue the nspcc has been given
600 000 pounds by the government to
support its
whistleblower helpline
but also a day after suela Bradman said
that Pakistani men were overrepresented
in this abuse the nspcc came out and
said oh you can't say that and that that
risks that risks a blind spot in our
analysis of these gangs Etc no the blind
spot we've had has been people ignoring
Pakistani grooming gangs that's where
the real blind spot has been now people
are very alert to other issues
the police have been oh they've actually
been pretty short in dealing with sex
abuse across the country but they've
been especially bad at dealing with
these gangs that's where the real blind
spot has been happening and I thought
that was just an unbelievable statement
they're more concerned with offending
the abusers than protecting these
com the most vulnerable yes people in
our country yes it's just utterly
shocking yes
um and and one can only hope that that
things have changed last week with this
new policy and and um I urge Watchers
and listeners to watch your film which
which actually is a very good
introduction as I hope this conversation
might have been and um
I wonder whether you'd be making another
film because it seems like it's an
ongoing story so so uh is it might you
be making more or yeah the GB News
investigates brand as it were the team
our mission is to cover stories which
has stories that have the biggest gap
between the interest paid by the
population and the interest paid by The
Establishment and um the political world
in particular we started with the
biggest version of that as of I think I
think I've demonstrated in this
conversation which is the grooming gang
Scandal there is a huge there's a huge
gap between interest of people and of
the establishment there
um and there'll be more films and
investigations and documentaries in that
space in general but I will not leave
The Grooming gang story behind now that
these policies are in holding the
government to accountability now yeah I
know and I hope others join in as well
lots of other Jonas done fantastic work
here yeah um Geraldine mcelvia the
mirror
basically Force the Telford inquiry
which found a thousand victims from the
1980s almost
she forced that because the the Telfer
Council said oh we don't need an
independent investigation we've done our
own
and indeed the man who wrote a letter to
the Home Secretary in 2015 saying we
don't need an independent inquiry he's
still the council leader
um Andrew Norful at the Times
blowing the lid off the Rotherham
scandal
he's still on top of this story and the
time still does excellent excellent work
on the grooming gang Scandal but it
should be more it should be more across
the rest of the media and um I hope yeah
with these policies there's now a I
suppose there's now a political
incentive to care because this is an
opportunity for people to check that the
government is doing what it says it will
do so even if it's the wrong incentive I
think the right incentive should be the
protection of women and girls regardless
of their abuser this I hope will usher
in more investigation well Charlie
Peters thank you so much for taking the
time to speak with me today thank you
and all the best of your important work
[Music]
thank you